hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to teach you how to convert
numbers into binary or base two which is
the number system used in virtually all
modern computers we'll start out with an
example of 13 the process we're going to
use is we're going to divide the number
in half and ignore the remainder so 13
divided by 2 is 6 with the remainder of
1 which we ignore and we're going to
keep repeating this process until we get
to the number 1 so dividing 6 and 1/2 we
get 3 dividing 3 and 1/2 we get 1 now
what we're going to do is we're going to
write a 1 below any of the numbers that
are odd and a 0 below any of the numbers
that are even so the number 1 is odd 3
is also odd 6 is an even number and 13
is an odd number and that's actually
going to give us our answer 13 will
equal 1 1 0 1 in binary you can do this
process for other numbers we'll do
another example like 244 and the step
we're going to do is we're going to keep
repeatedly dividing the number in half
and ignoring the remainder so we get 122
dividing in half again we get 61 then we
get 30 15 7 3 and finally 1 and once
again all we do now is we write a 1
below any number that's odd and a 0
below any number that's even so we have
1 1 1 1 we have an even number and then
we just fill out the rest and once again
that gives us our answer we can convert
244 into binary from these numbers
a final example will do 2014 we're going
to keep on dividing this number in half
ignoring the remainder and it's going to
be a few steps for this and now once
we're here we simply write a 1 below any
of the odd numbers and a 0 below any of
the even numbers and once again this
will give us the answer of 2014 in
binary I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions or on
twitter at pressure Locker